the other thing around genome sequencing
that I think a lot of people you know
have heard of but they probably don't
understand is when you get into all of
the gene editing right so whether it's
at the individual cell level or kind of
this DNA editing maybe talk a little bit
about it's kind of hard for me to see
that world happening if we don't
actually understand first right I kind
of have to understand that the genes and
the DNA and kind of what's going on
before you can even think about editing
butBut there's obviously technologies
out there that people kind of have heard
at a high level and how do you think
about that as maybe kind of a long-term
path that the the medical community is
likely to pursue whether it's just for
you know curing diseases and kind of
direct you know health applications
versus like hey I want to change the
color of my baby's eyes type stuff yeah
well I think the the extreme depths of
potential knowledge and the lack thereof
in biology
sounds like a daunting problem right so
we don't understand anything how can be
edited but I think this immense amount
of depth and complexity and the lack of
knowledge opens the door also to genius
right you can be very genius by saying
like maybe we don't have to know all
these things maybe we can hack it like
for example if you know a mutation does
some bad stuff but you have no idea what
you just know in the outcome is bad but
we cannot figure out what it actually
does maybe you don't need to figure that
out maybe you just remove that mutation
routine editing and you know maybe you
cut it out and replace it with a healthy
piece of DNA so the whole CRISPR
Revolution I think it's you know often
things get over height but Crispus a
little bit like the internet you know
everyone said the internet oh god it's
gonna change our lives forever
everything is gonna change and I was
like oh my god so not just these people
they are over hyping this but it was
just true I mean it is changing
everything and CRISPR is very similar
because CRISPR allows you to it's kind
of crazy when you think about it it
allows you to in a very targeted way
take any specific segment of the DNA and
replace it with any desired fragment you
want to put it through the nucleotide
you have three points
billion opiate has on your DNA they can
to the single nucleotide say okay at
that specific location how'd it out in
inject that sequence and if you and they
can do it in living organisms they can
base inject it into you and it would
kind of you know disperse it across your
whole body in theory and replace it in
all your cells which is extremely freaky
because it actually works right so you
could actually change your eye color and
theory while you're like living and well
I even change all kinds of things so
that is extremely freaky of course
there's a none you know enormous amount
of things that can go wrong you're
probably gonna die if you want to change
your eye color because some stuff is
gonna happen that no one you know was
considering so I wouldn't test it out at
home but in theory it's very possible
and
so we know a lot of things but compared
to what we should know it's basically
zero but that doesn't mean you can't do
absolutely amazing or shocking things
and of course I'm very you know we are
very focused on disease and keeping
people healthy and you know not not let
them age too fast and there are many
things you could do but of course you
need very very deep clinical trials for
that to prove safety especially if you
start editing genomes and living cupids
it's it's more regulatory issue I mean
scientifically it's definitely extremely
possible and not even that I mean you
can do it today and where do people get
so like let's say I want to take one of
those nucleotides and I want to replace
it right so I've identified that that
one is a bad one whatever for whatever
reason where do I get the replacement is
that something that I take from
somewhere else in the body is that
something that it's like quote unquote
lab-grown where does that replacement
one come from in that scenario so here
you know and these are great questions
because if you go into biotech and you
will learn about these things it's
absolutely stunning
you know how had certain things always
think that can't be that hard and how
easy certain things always think this
must be completely impossible and then
someone's like no it's cost five bucks
on the website you get and and it's like
stunning and this is one of these things
you can literally say here's my sequence
PTA a CGA CGA or something right thank
you I don't know where you get this from
but whatever you do your research and
say I want this little part of the
protein change these amino acids and so
I have you know these 24 nucleotide
sequence that I want to inject here you
can literally go on the website from
what any specific companies but you can
google that quickly copy paste your TTA
see these things in there take out your
credit card and they send it to you two
weeks later no way in a little to no way
and then you have them and they are
clean there you have a few billion of
these little sequences in there and
they're all led sequence and what are
people doing with those today are they
like injecting them
no there is a huge amount of stuff that
where this is use we do this every day
we order them every day so you know you
you need them and sequencing for example
for PCR reactions so they are called you
know these nucleotide sequences I hugely
new used all across both there for
example uses primers so we can use them
to base e have a little sequence that
reflects another sequence on the DNA and
if you put that into a mix and do some
stuff is it heated pick up and down and
put polymerase in it this enzyme then
these primers will anneal like they will
align to be complement here the
complement on the DNA and then start
reading that out like whatever comes
after so you can daisy say i want to
read out whatever is on the DNA after
that sequence let's actually sequencing
so you say okay if you want to read out
that specific part of the DNA what you
have to do the primer that you
synthesize that sits here and it aligns
here and then the polymerase enzyme
comes here and starts complementing the
rest of the DNA and then that gets put
on a sequencing machine and you read it
out and you see oh yeah this is my
primer i recognize that that's what i
designed and then what comes after is
the sequence that i was looking at so i
can see if you actually have a t there